Shure: (歌词)小黄花从出生那年就飘
Shure: (Lyrics) Little yellow flowers drifted since the year they were born.
Shure: (歌词)童年的荡秋千随记忆
Shure: (Lyrics) The swings of childhood float along with memories.
Shure: (歌词)多西拉索
Shure: (Lyrics) Do Re Mi Fa Sol
Shure: (歌词)那一天花落的那一天
Shure: (Lyrics) That day, the day the flowers fell.
Shure: (歌词)教室的那一间
Shure: (Lyrics) That classroom.
Shure: (歌词)我怎么看不见
Shure: (Lyrics) Why can't I see it?
Shure: (歌词)消失的下雨天
Shure: (Lyrics) The rainy days that disappeared.
Shure: (歌词)我好想再淋一遍
Shure: (Lyrics) I really want to get drenched again.
Shure: (歌词)没想到我失去勇气我还留着
Shure: (Lyrics) Didn't expect I'd still keep my courage after losing it.
Shure: (歌词)好想再问一遍
Shure: (Lyrics) Really want to ask again.
Shure: (歌词)刮风这天我试过牵着你手但偏偏
Shure: (Lyrics) On the windy day, I tried holding your hand but...
Shure: (歌词)有个人爱你很久
Shure: (Lyrics) Someone has loved you for a long time.
Shure: (歌词)但偏偏风
Shure: (Lyrics) But the wind...
Shure: (歌词)渐渐吹得好远
Shure: (Lyrics) Blows it farther and farther away.
Shure: (歌词)好不容易又能再多爱一天但故事
Shure: (Lyrics) Finally, I get to love you one more day, but the story...
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: (歌词)小黄花从出生那年就飘着
Shure: (Lyrics) Little yellow flowers drifted since the year they were born.
Shure: (歌词)童年的荡秋千随记忆一直晃到现在Ras
Shure: (Lyrics) The swings of childhood float along with memories until now.
Shure: (歌词)吹着前奏望着天空
Shure: (Lyrics) Playing the prelude, looking at the sky.
Shure: (歌词)我想起花瓣试着掉落
Shure: (Lyrics) I remember the petals trying to fall
Shure: (歌词)为你翘课的那一天花落的那一天
Shure: (Lyrics) The day I skipped class for you, the day the flowers fell
Shure: (歌词)教室的那一间我怎么看不见
Shure: (Lyrics) In that classroom, why couldn't I see
Shure: (歌词)消失的下雨天我好想再淋一遍
Shure: (Lyrics) The rainy days that disappeared, I really want to get drenched again
Shure: 没想到我失去勇气我还留着
Shure: I didn't expect that I would lose my courage, but I still hold on
Shure: 好想再问一遍你会等待还是离开
Shure: I really want to ask again, will you wait or will you leave
Shure: (歌词)刮风这天我试过握着你手
Shure: (Lyrics) On windy days, I tried to hold your hand
Shure: (歌词)但偏偏风渐渐大到我看你不见
Shure: (Lyrics) But the wind grew so strong that I couldn't see you anymore
Shure: 吓我一跳
Shure: You scared me
Shure: bye bye
Shure: Bye bye
Shure: 太棒了我们无敌了
Shure: Awesome, we're unbeatable
Shure: 这简直就是小周杰伦啊
Shure: This is just like a young Jay Chou
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 啊还是平的爽
Katrina: Ah, it's still nice to be flat
Katrina: 还是这种平的爽啊
Katrina: This kind of flat is still the best
Shure: 是我那个大的
Shure: It's my big one
Shure: 就是有点跟我想象的风
Shure: It's just a bit different from what I imagined
Katrina: 这个这会不会强迫症受不了
Katrina: Won't this trigger OCD?
Katrina: 我是能接受
Katrina: I can accept it
Katrina: 啊这下面还有两坨
Katrina: Ah, there are still two lumps below
Katrina: 这跟搁屎一样怎么
Katrina: How does this look like poop
Shure: (歌词)follow my lead
Shure: (Lyrics) Follow my lead
Shure: (歌词)follow me
Shure: (Lyrics) Follow me
Katrina: （歌词）我爱你
Katrina: (Lyrics) I love you
修硕(歌词)：follow me
Shure: (Lyrics) Follow me
Shure: (歌词)follow my lead
Shure: (Lyrics) Follow my lead
Shure: 歌词）i found a girl beautiful and free
Shure: (Lyrics) I found a girl beautiful and free
Shure: (歌词)i never knew you
Shure: (Lyrics) I never knew you
Shure: (歌词)i never knew you were someone waiting for me
Shure: (Lyrics) I never knew you were someone waiting for me
Shure: (歌词)we were just kids when we fell in love
Shure: (Lyrics) We were just kids when we fell in love
Shure: (歌词)not knowing what what it was
Shure: (Lyrics) Not knowing what it was
Shure: (歌词)now that i do
Shure: (Lyrics) Now that I do
Shure: (歌词)to my
Shure: (Lyrics) To my
Shure: 卧槽这个变调夹彻底不行了
Shure: Damn, this capo is completely useless
Shure: 你看他已经夹不紧了
Shure: Look, it can't clamp tightly anymore
Katrina: 老了
Katrina: It's old
Shure: 老了不中用了
Shure: It's old and useless
Shure: 反过来夹试试
Shure: Try clamping it the other way around
Shure: (歌词)i found the light
Shure: (Lyrics) I found the light
Shure: (歌词)for me darling just time
Shure: (Lyrics) For me darling just time
Shure: (歌词)我祈祷拥有一颗透明的心灵
Shure: (Lyrics) I pray to have a clear heart
Shure: (歌词)和会流泪的眼睛
Shure: (Lyrics) And eyes that can cry
Shure: (歌词)哦给你再去相信的勇气
Shure: (Lyrics) Oh, to give you the courage to believe again
Shure: (歌词)哦越过谎言去拥抱你
Shure: (Lyrics) Oh, to embrace you beyond the lies
Shure: (歌词)每当我找不到存在的意义
Shure: (Lyrics) Every time I can't find the meaning of existence
Shure: (歌词)每当我迷失在黑夜里
Shure: (Lyrics) Every time I get lost in the dark
Shure: (歌词)哦夜空中最亮的星
Shure: (Lyrics) Oh, the brightest star in the night sky
Shure: (歌词) 请你指引我前行
Shure: (Lyrics) Please guide me forward
Shure: 你会free style吗
Shure: Can you freestyle?
Katrina: 不会还没有修炼
Katrina: No, I haven't trained
Katrina: 修炼到那个程度
Katrina: to that level yet.
Shure: 可以来段说唱就这样
Shure: You could just do some rap like this.
Katrina: 我我吗呵呵
Katrina: Me? Haha
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 看随便套一个说唱词
Shure: Just pick any rap lyrics.
Shure: 这样就可以
Shure: That will do.
Shure: 比如说
Shure: For example,
Shure: 想想有什么说唱
Shure: Think of some rap.
Shure: 你平常喜欢的rapper都有哪些
Shure: Which rappers do you usually like?
Katrina: 马思维和沙一汀
Katrina: Ma Siwei and Shayeting.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 就随便套一个他的
Shure: Just pick any of their songs.
Shure: 所以你睡了没好吧
Shure: So, are you asleep? Alright.
Shure: 想想词是什么
Shure: Think of the lyrics.
Shure: 感受这种小清新的感觉
Shure: Feel this fresh vibe.
Katrina: release
Katrina: Release.
Shure: (歌词)你有多久没有出门
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you went out?
Shure: (歌词)多久没有拉
Shure: (Lyrics) How long since you pulled
Shure: (歌词)多久没有出门
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you went out?
Shure: (歌词)多久没有拉开窗帘
Shure: (Lyrics) How long since you opened the curtains?
Shure: (歌词)感到清晨这段时间可能哒哒哒
Shure: (Lyrics) To feel the morning, maybe da da da
Shure: 不行
Shure: No.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: (歌词)多久没有出门
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been since you went out?
Shure: (歌词)多久没有拉开窗帘
Shure: (Lyrics) How long since you opened the curtains?
Shure: (歌词)看到清晨这段时间
Shure: (Lyrics) To see the morning time
Shure: (歌词)看着你的脸
Shure: (Lyrics) Looking at your face
Shure: (歌词)弹动着你的精神
Shure: (Lyrics) Shaking your spirit
Shure: (歌词)你把爱我删掉
Shure: (Lyrics) You deleted my love
Shure: (歌词)撕掉你的空头支票
Shure: (Lyrics) Tore up your empty promises
Shure: (歌词)跟着哒哒哒哒
Shure: (Lyrics) Follow the da da da da
Shure: (歌词)真的太暗示这次睡了没
Shure: (Lyrics) Really hinting if you’ve slept this time
Shure: (歌词)所以你睡了没
Shure: (Lyrics) So, have you slept?
Shure: (歌词)你有好多久没有
Shure: (Lyrics) How long has it been
Shure: (歌词)我只能坐上门椅
Shure: (Lyrics) Since you last did?
Shure: (歌词)拉开窗帘看到那个清晨
Shure: (Lyrics) I can only sit on the chair by the door
Shure: (歌词)这段时间喝了太多啤酒
Shure: (Lyrics) Pull back the curtains to see the morning
Shure: (歌词)和你分开之后我的天都塌了
Shure: (Lyrics) Drank too much beer during this time
Shure: (歌词)没有动力过的没有精神啊
Shure: (Lyrics) After we broke up, my world collapsed
Shure: (歌词)不管那里是什么样的天气
Shure: (Lyrics) No motivation, no energy
Shure: (歌词)怎样丢掉这个年纪不该有的细腻
Shure: (Lyrics) No matter what the weather is
Shure: (歌词)和你我都雪亮
Shure: (Lyrics) How to lose the sensitivity of this age
Shure: (歌词)从不向人展示岸的那面
Shure: (Lyrics) Both you and I are clear
Shure: (歌词)所以你睡了没
Shure: (Lyrics) Never show the other side to people
Shure: 是不是就是这个感觉了
Shure: So, is this how it feels?
Katrina: 完全变一个风格还有
Katrina: Completely changed the style, and
Katrina: 你拿算了
Katrina: Just take it
Katrina: 你听过没
Katrina: Have you heard it?
Shure: 没有啊
Shure: No, I haven't.
Katrina: （歌词）不知道算是谁的错
Katrina: (Lyrics) Don’t know whose fault it is
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Katrina: （歌词）两个人的话
Katrina: (Lyrics) If it’s just between two people
Shure: 这叫冷战嘛
Shure: Is this called a cold war?
Katrina: 哦冷哦对
Katrina: Oh, cold war, right
Katrina: 搞混了TT的冷战
Katrina: Got mixed up with TT’s cold war
Shure: 冷战时聪明女人的做法什么鬼
Shure: What’s with the smart woman’s way during a cold war?
Katrina: 这是巨难用
Katrina: This is really hard to use
Katrina: 我还买了10个
Katrina: I even bought 10 of them
Shure: 然真的有吉他谱这个东西
Shure: So, there really is such a thing as guitar tabs
Katrina: 不如我直接贴明信片吧
Katrina: I might as well just stick postcards
Shure: 真的是这个调子吗
Shure: Is this really the tune?
Shure: (歌词)不知道算是谁的错
Shure: (Lyrics) Don’t know whose fault it is
Shure: (歌词)两个人变得话不多
Shure: (Lyrics) Two people become less talkative
Shure: (歌词)气氛尴尬但不戳破
Shure: (Lyrics) The atmosphere is awkward but we don’t break it
Shure: (歌词)都得过且过
Shure: (Lyrics) Just get by
Shure: (歌词)当发现互相都猜透
Shure: (Lyrics) When we realize we’ve figured each other out
Shure: (歌词)伤人的话都不想说
Shure: (Lyrics) We don’t want to say hurtful words
Shure: (歌词)气氛尴尬戳破都得过且过
Shure: (Lyrics) The atmosphere is awkward, we don’t break it, just get by
Shure: (歌词)不找我我不找你都不主动
Shure: (Lyrics) If you don't look for me, I won't look for you, neither of us will make a move.
Shure: (歌词)该怎么去形容你最贴切
Shure: (Lyrics) How can I describe you in the most fitting way?
Shure: (歌词)拿什么跟你作比较才算特别
Shure: (Lyrics) What should I compare you to that's truly special?
Shure: (歌词)对你的感觉强烈却又不太了解
Shure: (Lyrics) My feelings for you are strong, yet I don't really understand them.
Shure: (歌词)舒服却又像风捉摸不住
Shure: (Lyrics) Comfortable, yet elusive like the wind.
Shure: (歌词)像手腕上散发发的香水味
Shure: (Lyrics) Like the scent of perfume from my wrist.
Shure: (歌词)像爱不释手的
Shure: (Lyrics) Like something I can't let go of.
Shure: (歌词)红色高跟鞋
Shure: (Lyrics) Red high heels.
Shure: (歌词)独自生活30年
Shure: (Lyrics) Living alone for 30 years.
Shure: 就这样的一个和弦进行
Shure: It's just this kind of chord progression.
Shure: 可以唱好多歌
Shure: You can sing a lot of songs with it.
Shure: 就是456进行
Shure: It's just 4-5-6 progression.
Shure: 再比如说那个d调的卡农
Shure: For example, the Canon in D.
Shure: (歌词)是的我看见到处是阳光
Shure: (Lyrics) Yes, I see sunshine everywhere.
Shure: (歌词)快乐在城市上空在城市上空飘荡
Shure: (Lyrics) Happiness floats above the city, above the city.
Shure: (歌词)恋爱ING happy ING想
Shure: (Lyrics) Love ING, happy ING, thinking.
Shure: 哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da.
Shure: (歌词)恋爱ING happy happy i n g
Shure: (Lyrics) Love ING, happy happy ING.
Shure: (歌词)哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒不停
Shure: (Lyrics) Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da non-stop.
Shure: 还有这就是卡农吗
Shure: And there's this, which is Canon, right?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: (歌词)哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
Shure: (Lyrics) Da da da da da da da da da.
Katrina: （歌词）当你抬起头
Katrina: (Lyrics) When you look up.
Katrina: （歌词）你正看向我
Katrina: (Lyrics) You are looking at me.
Katrina: （歌词）夜空倒映着夏夜灿烂的烟火
Katrina: (Lyrics) The night sky reflects the brilliant summer fireworks.
Katrina: （歌词）黑暗的心从此坚定永远
Katrina: (Lyrics) The dark heart from then on becomes firm forever.
Shure: 我会和
Shure: I'll go and...
Katrina: 今天中午点什么外卖
Katrina: What should we order for lunch today?
Shure: 早上不是吃过了吗
Shure: Didn't we already have breakfast?
Shure: 中午还吃吗
Shure: Are we eating lunch too?
Shure: 今天晚上就回去了
Shure: I'm going back tonight.
Katrina: 谁啊
Katrina: Who?
Shure: 我
Shure: Me.
Katrina: 为啥
Katrina: Why?
Shure: 因为我明天要回去上班了
Shure: Because I have to go back to work tomorrow.
Shure: 没办法呀
Shure: I can't help it.
Katrina: 那你今天就是完全滚蛋是吗
Katrina: So you're completely ditching us today?
Shure: 对我就是这么想的
Shure: Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
Shure: 但还没有跟杨老板说
Shure: But I haven't told Jake yet.
Shure: 然后周一上班之后
Shure: And then, after going to work on Monday,
Shure: 要跟leader提辞职的事情
Shure: I'll need to talk to the leader about resigning.
Katrina: 哎呀你这变动真的
Katrina: Oh man, this change is really...
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 你再不提
Shure: If you don't bring it up soon,
Shure: 我后面还要出去玩
Shure: I still have plans to go out later.
Shure: 那不至于
Shure: It's not that big of a deal.
Shure: 转正他们不稀的要我
Shure: They don't really care about making me permanent.
Shure: (歌词)爱上你是多余光
Shure: (Lyrics) Falling in love with you is just a superfluous light.
Shure: 大石碎胸口
Shure: Crushing a stone on my chest.
Shure: 夹子真的要扔了
Shure: The clip really needs to be thrown away.
Shure: (歌词)欲望还想
Shure: (Lyrics) Desire still wants.
Shure: (歌词)继续做欲望
Shure: (Lyrics) To continue being desire.
Shure: (歌词)而爱
Shure: (Lyrics) And love.
Shure: (歌词)海港已经不知去向
Shure: (Lyrics) The harbor has already disappeared.
Shure: (歌词)此刻他最大自诩与众心没有潮汐的梦
Shure: (Lyrics) At this moment he boasts himself with no tidal dreams.
Shure: (歌词)胸口已暮色苍茫
Shure: (Lyrics) The chest is already dim.
Shure: 万能青年旅店
Shure: Omnipotent Youth Society.
Shure: 简称万青
Shure: Also known as Wan Qing.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure: 都比较有名的乐队
Shure: They're a pretty famous band.
Shure: 万青
Shure: Wan Qing.
Shure: 犹抱琵琶半遮面
Shure: The pipa is half-covered.
Shure: 锦瑟无端五十弦
Shure: The zither has fifty strings for no reason.
Shure: 一弦一柱思华年
Shure: Each string, each column, thinks of the past.
Shure: 庄生晓梦迷蝴蝶
Shure: Zhuangzi dreams of butterflies.
Shure: 这什么什么诗来着锦瑟
Shure: What poem is this from? Jinse?
Katrina: 让我再看你一遍
Katrina: Let me see you again.
Katrina: 从南到北
Katrina: From south to north.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 我找找安河桥
Shure: Let me find the Anhe Bridge.
Katrina: 你去过安河桥没有
Katrina: Have you been to Anhe Bridge?
Shure: 安河桥北是吧
Shure: Anhe Bridge North, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 我应该在那换乘过
Shure: I think I transferred there once.
Shure: 让我再看你一眼
Shure: Let me see you again.
Shure: 从南到北
Shure: From south to north.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Shure: 怎么这么奇怪啊
Shure: Why is this so weird?
Shure: （歌词）让我在看你一眼
Shure: (Lyrics) Let me take another look at you
Shure: （歌词）从南到北
Shure: (Lyrics) From south to north
Shure: 卧槽这好低啊
Shure: Whoa, this is so low
Katrina: 天呐好久没有听到鸡叫
Katrina: Wow, it's been so long since I heard a rooster crow
Shure: （歌词）让我再看你一眼
Shure: (Lyrics) Let me take another look at you
Shure: （歌词）从南到北
Shure: (Lyrics) From south to north
Shure: （歌词）像是飞五环路
Shure: (Lyrics) Like flying along the Fifth Ring Road
Shure: 蒙
Shure: Confused
Shure: （歌词）蒙蒙住蒙住的双眼
Shure: (Lyrics) Blindfolding, blindfolding those eyes
Shure: （歌词）请你再想一遍
Shure: (Lyrics) Please think about it again
Shure: 哈哈哈不行了
Shure: Haha, I can't do it anymore
Shure: 我绷不住了
Shure: I can't hold it in
Shure: 怎么弹呢
Shure: How to play this?
Shure: （歌词）当当当当当
Shure: (Lyrics) Da da da da da
Shure: （歌词）当当当当当当当当当
Shure: (Lyrics) Da da da da da da da da da
Shure: （歌词）当当当
Shure: (Lyrics) Da da da
Katrina: 天每次做这种手工
Katrina: Every time I do this kind of handicraft
Katrina: 感觉自己的那个手脚巨不协调
Katrina: I feel like my hands and feet are so uncoordinated
Katrina: 看我的手指
Katrina: Look at my fingers
Shure: 砍了
Shure: Cut it off
Katrina: 什么砍了
Katrina: What cut it off?
Shure: 手脚砍了
Shure: Cut off your hands and feet
Shure: 自由制造啊
Shure: Freedom to create
Shure: 来我们刷刷我们北邮的这个新视频
Shure: Let's check out our new video from Beiyou
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Shure: 我操这不是旭书记吗
Shure: Damn, isn't that Secretary Xu?
Shure: 你看看书一讲话
Shure: Look, as soon as he speaks
Shure: 啪啪啪这闪光灯就上来了
Shure: The flashlights start popping
Shure: 我跟你讲哎
Shure: I'm telling you
Shure: 关于我的学习
Shure: About my studies
Shure: （歌词）猪猪猪猪猪猪猪猪猪猪猪
Shure: (Lyrics) Pig pig pig pig pig pig pig pig pig pig pig
Shure: （歌词）亲爱的人哦
Shure: (Lyrics) My dear one, oh
Shure: 听过这个歌吗
Shure: Have you heard this song?
Shure: 亲密爱人
Shure: Intimate Lover
Shure: 梅艳芳
Shure: Anita Mui
Shure: （歌词）今夜还吹
Shure: (Lyrics) Tonight still blows
Shure: （歌词）今夜还吹着风
Shure: (Lyrics) Tonight the wind still blows
Shure: （歌词）想起你好温柔
Shure: (Lyrics) Thinking of you, so gentle
Shure: （歌词）有你的日子分外的轻松
Shure: (Lyrics) Days with you are especially relaxing
Shure: （歌词）也不是无影踪
Shure: (Lyrics) Not exactly without a trace
Shure: （歌词）只是只是想你太浓
Shure: (Lyrics) It's just, just that I miss you so much
Shure: （歌词）怎么会无时无刻把你梦
Shure: (Lyrics) How could I dream of you all the time
Shure: （歌词）爱的路上有你我并
Shure: (Lyrics) On the road of love with you, I am not lonely
Shure: （歌词）不寂寞你对我那么的好
Shure: (Lyrics) You treat me so well
Shure: （歌词）其实分外轻松
Shure: (Lyrics) Actually, it's especially relaxing
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 我是不应该写会论文
Shure: Shouldn't I be writing my thesis?
Katrina: 不去打扫卫生吧
Katrina: How about cleaning up instead?
Shure: 别了写论文吧
Shure: No, I'll write my thesis.
Katrina: 今天下午人家要来
Katrina: People are coming over this afternoon.
Katrina: 哎脏成那个样子
Katrina: Ugh, it's so dirty.
Katrina: 真能忍
Katrina: How can you stand it?
Shure: 我可以
Shure: I can manage.
Katrina: 不行
Katrina: No way.
Katrina: 大扫除
Katrina: Big cleanup.
Shure: 我只要把我的房间收拾干净
Shure: I'll just clean my own room.
Katrina: 不行
Katrina: No.
Shure: （歌词）如果感到悲伤
Shure: (Lyrics) If you feel sad
Shure: （歌词）我会陪你晒太阳
Shure: (Lyrics) I'll bask in the sun with you
Shure: 哦你听过那个young for you吗
Shure: Oh, have you heard that "Young for You"?
Katrina: 听过
Katrina: Yes, I have.
Shure: （歌词）Sunday is coming
Shure: (Lyrics) Sunday is coming
Shure: 我唱那个唱的巨像
Shure: I sing it really well, you know.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: Did you know that?
Shure: 高中什么
Shure: In high school...
Katrina: 可喜欢听这首歌
Katrina: I loved listening to this song.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: （歌词）oh sunday's coming
Shure: (Lyrics) oh sunday's coming
Shure: （歌词） wanna drive my car to your apartment with your brother
Shure: (Lyrics) wanna drive my car to your apartment with your brother
Shure: （歌词）like a star for
Shure: (Lyrics) like a star for
Shure: （歌词）just to say the weather will be raining hard
Shure: (Lyrics) just to say the weather will be raining hard
Shure: （歌词）but i know the sign for us
Shure: (Lyrics) but i know the sign for us
Shure: （歌词）oh lazy seagull wanna find me from the dark
Shure: (Lyrics) oh lazy seagull wanna find me from the dark
Shure: （歌词）i dress my jeans and feed my monkey banana
Shure: (Lyrics) i dress my jeans and feed my monkey banana
Shure: （歌词）i h o 4
Shure: (Lyrics) i h o 4
Shure: （歌词）shall face her abroad
Shure: (Lyrics) shall face her abroad
Shure: （歌词）said i were young oh dancing the beach
Shure: (Lyrics) said i were young oh dancing the beach
Shure: （歌词）we came so long it seems the passion
Shure: (Lyrics) we came so long it seems the passion
Shure: （歌词）never gone哈哈哈哈
Shure: (Singing) never gone, hahaha
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 在哪呢在这唱呢
Katrina: Where are you singing?
Katrina: 还是就在公园这唱
Katrina: Are you singing in the park?
Shure: 我也不知道
Shure: I don't know either.
Shure: 音乐的力量music power
Shure: The power of music, music power!
Shure: 们听点新裤子的吧
Shure: Let's listen to some New Pants.
Shure: （歌词）勇敢的你站在这里
Shure: (Singing) Brave you stand here.
Shure: （歌词）的告别我都想走不敢回头
Shure: (Singing) Saying goodbye, I want to leave but don't dare to look back.
Shure: （歌词）不能再见的朋友
Shure: (Singing) Friends we can't meet again.
Shure: （歌词）有人堕落有人疯了
Shure: (Singing) Some fall, some go crazy.
Shure: （歌词）有人随着风去了我难过
Shure: (Singing) Some go with the wind, I feel sad.
Shure: 唱裤子的歌
Shure: Singing New Pants' songs.
Shure: 你一定要大舌头
Shure: You need to have a lisp.
Shure: 不然话你唱不出它的神韵
Shure: Otherwise, you can't capture its essence.
Shure: （歌词）忘了吧那摇滚乐
Shure: (Singing) Forget that rock music.
Shure: （歌词）不欢不服的时代
Shure: (Singing) The era of unyielding spirit.
Shure: 带你快速听完新裤子
Shure: I'll let you quickly listen to New Pants.
Shure: 杨老板是不是两天没发钱了
Shure: Hasn't Jake paid for two days?
Shure: 催催杨老板
Shure: Hurry Jake up.
Shure: 算的那个是
Shure: The calculated amount is...
Katrina: 那为啥不直接发那300块钱
Katrina: Then why not just send the 300 yuan directly?
Shure: 因为红包他最多就那什
Shure: Because the red envelope has a limit...
Katrina: 可以转账300块钱那第一天怎么付的
Katrina: You can transfer 300 yuan, how was it done on the first day?
Shure: 因为第一天是150
Shure: Because the first day was 150 yuan.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Shure: 谁啊今天来的同学
Shure: Who came today?
Katrina: the third boy
Katrina: The third boy.
Shure: the third boy的
Shure: The third boy?
Shure: 这又是哪个boy
Shure: Which boy is that?
Katrina: 就是那个
Katrina: It's that one.
Shure: 济南那个
Shure: The one from Jinan?
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yes, yes.
Shure: 那不是the second boy吗
Shure: Isn't he the second boy?
Shure: 咦咦
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 什么我只谈了一段恋爱
Katrina: What? I've only been in one relationship.
Shure: 我只谈了一段恋爱
Shure: I've only been in one relationship.
Katrina: 我还能做一张我再做一会
Katrina: I can still make one more, I'll do it for a bit longer.
Shure: 快做快做
Shure: Hurry up, hurry up.
Shure: 对我们打扫卫生去
Shure: Okay, let's go clean up.
Katrina: 你可以先把这些垃圾盒扔到外面
Katrina: Can you take these trash boxes outside first?
Katrina: 扔到真有垃圾桶
Katrina: Throw them into a real trash bin.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 我女朋友说刚才化妆没开灯
Shure: My girlfriend said she did her makeup without turning on the light.
Shure: 妆化浓了
Shure: She put on too much makeup.
Shure: 哈哈去接孩子放学
Shure: Haha, she's going to pick up the kids from school.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 好的妈妈
Shure: Yes, mom.
Shure: 受不了了
Shure: I can't take it anymore.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 学你呢
Shure: I’m imitating you.
Katrina: 我我什么时候
Katrina: When did I ever...
Shure: （歌词）我会和他结婚
Shure: (Lyrics) I will marry him.
Shure: （歌词）在他走的每个角落各自建
Shure: (Lyrics) Build something at every corner he walks.
Shure: （歌词）的女孩时间久了也很美
Shure: (Lyrics) Girls who have been together for a long time are also beautiful.
Shure: （歌词）忘了吧那摇滚乐
Shure: (Lyrics) Forget about rock music.
Shure: （歌词）奔腾不复的时代
Shure: (Lyrics) The era of galloping is gone.
Shure: （歌词）我倒下后不敢回头
Shure: (Lyrics) After I fall, I dare not look back.
Shure: （歌词）不能再见的朋友
Shure: (Lyrics) Friends who can never meet again.
Shure: （歌词）有人疯了有人随着风去了我难过
Shure: (Lyrics) Some went crazy, some went with the wind, and I am sad.
Shure: 好久没晒过衣服
Shure: Haven't sun-dried clothes in a long time.
Shure: 我自打搬到本部之后
Shure: Ever since I moved to the main campus,
Shure: 全是拿那个烘干机烘的
Shure: I've been using the dryer for everything.
Shure: 之前住沙河那边的
Shure: Back when I lived in Shahe,
Shure: 我们搬过三次宿舍都搬麻了
Shure: We moved dorms three times, totally numb to it.
Shure: 人都就越搬越差
Shure: Each move was worse than the last.
Shure: 你知道吗我
Shure: You know, I...
Shure: 我们最开始就是来新学校的时候去的
Shure: When we first came to the new school,
Shure: 是那个最牛逼的宿舍
Shure: We were in the best dorm.
Shure: 就是刚新建好的那种
Shure: It was brand new.
Shure: 对沙河的一个叫S6的宿舍
Shure: Yeah, in Shahe, a dorm called S6.
Shure: 我靠那个真的就是特别好
Shure: Man, it was really great.
Katrina: 特别就我站在楼下
Katrina: Especially when I was standing downstairs.
Katrina: 给人感觉好像小小的水泥地啊
Katrina: It felt like a small concrete ground.
Shure: 甭提了哎
Shure: Don’t even mention it, ugh.
Shure: 我说甭提了
Shure: I said don’t mention it.
Shure: 哇好香啊
Shure: Wow, it smells so good.
Shure: 谁家又烤烧烤了
Shure: Who’s grilling BBQ again?
Shure: 还烤海鲜呢
Shure: They're even grilling seafood.
Shure: 好像是吧
Shure: Seems like it, right?
Shure: 什么狗逼
Shure: What the heck?
Shure: 骂谁呢
Shure: Who are you cursing at?
Shure: 恁咋不早说
Shure: Why didn't you say earlier?
Shure: 咱俩谋以后
Shure: Let's plan for the future
Shure: 我到底
Shure: What am I...
Katrina: 偷偷掉眼泪
Katrina: Secretly shedding tears
Shure: （歌词）什么让你难过
Shure: (Lyrics) What makes you sad
Katrina: 人生海海
Katrina: Life is like the sea
Shure: 人生海海
Shure: Life is like the sea
Katrina: 你看过这本书吗
Katrina: Have you read this book?
Shure: 没有觉得
Shure: No, I don't think so
Katrina: 这是我最喜欢的一本书
Katrina: It's my favorite book
Shure: 谁的
Shure: Whose?
Katrina: 忘了
Katrina: Forgot
Shure: 哎呀好下头啊你这个
Shure: Oh man, that's frustrating
Shure: 你这么说完我好像有有印象
Shure: Now that you mention it, it sounds familiar
Shure: 人生海海
Shure: Life is like the sea
Katrina: 送我的生日礼物
Katrina: It was a birthday gift
Katrina: 小学
Katrina: Elementary school
Shure: 小学
Shure: Elementary school
Katrina: 小学那时候看名著呢钢铁是怎样炼成的
Katrina: Back then, I read classics like "How the Steel Was Tempered"
Katrina: 很喜欢看书
Katrina: I loved reading
Katrina: 卧槽边角边还能做人真棒
Katrina: Wow, being able to be a good person even in tough times is amazing
Shure: （歌词）忘了吧那要滚远
Shure: (Lyrics) Forget it, just go away
Katrina: 也是北邮的
Katrina: He's also from our university
Shure: 啊我还有他的跟他的合照呢
Shure: Ah, I have a photo with him
Shure: 给你看看
Shure: Let me show you
Shure: 那是大一下的时候还是大二下的时候
Shure: It was either in the first or second year of university
Shure: 忘了
Shure: Forgot
Katrina: 他是哪个专业的
Katrina: Which major was he in?
Shure: 跟我们一个学院
Shure: Same college as us
Katrina: 国教的
Katrina: International Education
Shure: 国际学院
Shure: International College
Shure: 我们不叫国教
Shure: We don't call it International Education
Katrina: 我们学校的国际学院叫国教国际教育学院
Katrina: At our school, International College is called International Education
Shure: 没有我们只是因为
Shure: No, we just...
Shure: 卧槽那时候感觉还挺年轻
Shure: Wow, I felt pretty young back then
Shure: 你别说我
Shure: Don't talk about me
Katrina: 怎么了
Katrina: What's wrong?
Shure: 感觉没有现在这么沧桑
Shure: It doesn't feel as worn out as now.
Shure: 还是没有什么变化呀
Shure: Still, no big changes.
Katrina: 没有我感觉你现在年轻
Katrina: No, I think you look younger now.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 现在有一种很自由的感觉
Katrina: Now there's a sense of freedom.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哎我这相册里都是什么东西
Shure: Hey, what's all this stuff in my photo album?
Katrina: 前男友合照还没删呢
Katrina: You still haven't deleted photos with your ex-boyfriend?
Katrina: 太多照片了
Katrina: Too many photos.
Shure: 我也没删
Shure: I haven't deleted them either.
Katrina: 到时候谈了新的再删
Katrina: Delete them when you start dating someone new.
Shure: 我一直就没删
Shure: I've never deleted them.
Katrina: 你女朋友查手机吗
Katrina: Does your girlfriend check your phone?
Shure: 你以为你前女友也是他呀
Shure: Do you think your ex-girlfriend is him?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 这是我那时候剃寸头的时候
Shure: This is when I had a buzz cut.
Katrina: 哎呦好real啊
Katrina: Wow, that's so real.
Katrina: 这谁这你追的
Katrina: Who's this? Someone you chased after?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Uh...
Katrina: 你怎么没火啊
Katrina: How come you didn't become popular?
Shure: 特别像那个杨策
Shure: Looks a lot like Yang Ce.
Shure: 啊你知道杨策
Shure: Do you know Yang Ce?
Katrina: 大概知道他长啥样我好像看过他那剧
Katrina: I kind of know what he looks like. I think I've seen his show.
Shure: 无聊的渺小的
Shure: Boring and insignificant.
Katrina: 这板呀都不能用了
Katrina: This board is unusable.
Katrina: 这油的话我应该是够了
Katrina: I should have enough oil.
Shure: 这是刚长出来一点
Shure: It's just started to grow a bit.
Shure: 正在恢复的状态
Shure: It's in recovery.
Katrina: 听见他们好像回来了
Katrina: I think I hear them coming back.
Shure: 我会认真努力工作
Shure: I will work hard and seriously.
Shure: 呦你们回来了啊
Shure: Oh, you're back?
Jake:有电吗
Jake: Is there power?
Jake:你们有电吗
Jake: Do you have power?
其他人：你没电了
Others: You're out of power.
Katrina: 我呢
Katrina: What about me?
Shure: 你没电了
Shure: You're out of power.
Katrina: 像这么用心的摸鱼
Katrina: So dedicated to slacking off.
Shure: 你这么用心的摸鱼居然没被发现天
Shure: You're so dedicated to slacking off, and yet nobody noticed.
Katrina: 不是我做这么些东西呢
Katrina: It's not like I made all this stuff.
Shure: 哎别提了
Shure: Ah, don't even mention it.
Shure: 姚老板我在这兢兢业业的收拾院子
Shure: Jake, I've been diligently cleaning the yard.
Jake:哎呀没关系
Jake: Oh, it's fine.
Shure: 就在这坐着摸鱼
Shure: Just sitting here slacking off.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Alice:快递回来了吗
Alice: Has the package arrived?
Jake:快递回来了
Jake: The package is here.
Katrina: 我都不想说你这是什么呢
Katrina: I don't even want to know what that is.
Alice:是不是我的啥
Alice: Is it my stuff?
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice:小雏菊
Alice: Little daisies.
Shure: Daisy呵呵
Shure: Daisies, hehe.
其他人：看不起谁现在五块钱了
Others: Who looks down on 5 yuan now?
Shure: 呵呵呵屌丝饮料
Shure: Hehe, cheap drink.
其他人：还屌丝什么
Others: What's cheap about it?
Jake:什么5块钱啊
Jake: What's 5 yuan?
Tasha: 冰红茶哦
Tasha: Iced tea.
其他人：冰红茶都5块了哦
Others: Even iced tea is 5 yuan now.
Shure: 就是这个大瓶
Shure: This big bottle.
Shure: 就是原来他500毫升是卖3块钱
Shure: It used to be 3 yuan for 500 ml.
Shure: 然后一升的卖4块钱
Shure: Then 4 yuan for a liter.
Shure: 然后所以
Shure: So...
Shure: 大家称这个4块钱这个为屌丝饮料
Shure: Everyone called the 4 yuan one the cheap drink.
Jake:哦 4块钱还屌丝
Jake: Oh, 4 yuan is still cheap.
Shure: 然后哈哈哈
Shure: And then, hahaha.
Jake:咦个EOg币呢
Jake: Where's the EOg coin?
Jake:我靠呵呵呵
Jake: Damn, hahaha.
Shure: 然后然后现在这个涨价涨到5块了
Shure: And now the price has gone up to 5 yuan.
Shure: 大家纷纷喊买不起了
Shure: Everyone is saying they can't afford it.
Jake:呵呵呵真屌丝
Jake: Hehehe, really cheap.
Shure: （歌词）有人随着风去
Shure: (Lyrics) Some people follow the wind.
Shure: 这不都我做的吗
Shure: Didn't I make all this?
Alice:要不我给这拆了吧
Alice: Should I take this apart?
其他人：操这么屌
Others: Damn, so cool.
Shure: 我做的厉害吧
Shure: Isn't my work impressive?
Jake:来我帮你
Jake: Let me help you.
Alice:没事没事
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:牛
Jake: Awesome.
其他人：你是傻逼
Others: You're an idiot.
Shure: 我他妈弄死你
Shure: I'm gonna fucking kill you.
Jake:我来看看
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:哇这么这么牛逼
Jake: Wow, this is so awesome.
Shure: 爱自己是终身浪漫的开始
Shure: Loving yourself is the beginning of a lifelong romance.
Shure: 这个很好看
Shure: This looks really good.
Shure: 我要这个
Shure: I want this one.
Katrina: 这个定价多少呢
Katrina: How much is this priced at?
Shure: 卧槽这好帅啊这鞋
Shure: Whoa, these shoes are so cool.
其他人：0.5个EGO币
Others: 0.5 EGO coins.
Shure: 别赶路感受路
Shure: Don't rush, enjoy the journey.
Shure: 哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Katrina: 都是我说的
Katrina: I said all of that.
其他人：这都是你自己写的
Others: You wrote all of this yourself?
Katrina: 自己自己设计自己说的
Katrina: Designed and said all by myself.
Katrina: 这是我的real
Katrina: This is my real...
Katrina: eal那种
Katrina: ...real thing.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
其他人：真的吗
Others: Really?
Shure: 你差点就信了吧
Shure: You almost believed it, right?
其他人：我信够吧
Others: I totally believed it.
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 我给大家签个名吧
Shure: Let me give everyone an autograph.
Shure: 你要我的亲笔签名吗
Shure: Do you want my autograph?
其他人：要要了就从0.5ego币变成0.1ego币了
Others: If we get it, the price drops from 0.5 EGO coins to 0.1 EGO coins.
Shure: 哎昨儿昨儿
Shure: Hey, hey.
Shure: 那白板笔呢
Shure: Where's the whiteboard marker?
其他人：在那在那
Others: Over there, over there.
Katrina: 签名呢就是比较那艺术性
Katrina: The signature should be artistic.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 签到这边还是那边
Shure: Should I sign here or over there?
Katrina: 哎呀这边
Katrina: Over here.
Shure: 竖着牵横着牵
Shure: Vertical or horizontal?
Katrina: 这不看你吗
Katrina: It's up to you.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 你赶紧火了
Katrina: You gotta get famous quickly.
Katrina: 赶紧火了
Katrina: Get famous quickly.
Katrina: 然后拿着卖钱
Katrina: Then sell it for money.
Tasha: 拿剪刀了我
Tasha: I grabbed the scissors.
Katrina: 修
Katrina: Shure...
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Shure: 这是百鸟词典的签名啊
Shure: This is the signature of the Hundred Birds Dictionary.
Shure: 你看啊这是100的百对吧
Shure: Look, this is the "hundred" in "hundred", right?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Shure: 嗯然后这么看这是一个鸟
Shure: Yeah, and if you look at it this way, it's a bird.
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Shure: 然后词是这个言
Shure: And then the "word" part is this "yan".
Shure: 字旁是繁体的那个言吗
Shure: The radical is the traditional "yan", right?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Shure: 嗯然后词
Shure: Yeah, and then "word".
Katrina: 这个呢
Katrina: What about this?
Shure: 然后这就是点吗
Shure: And this is a dot.
Katrina: 这是点
Katrina: This is a dot.
Shure: 点不是那么写的吗你
Shure: Isn't the dot written like this? You...
Shure: 把这个都去掉
Shure: Remove all of this.
Shure: 都遮上你看这个
Shure: Cover everything up, look at this.
Katrina: 这确实值几千块钱
Katrina: This is definitely worth a few thousand bucks.
Katrina: 这个设计
Katrina: This design.
Shure: 这个是我自己设计的
Shure: I designed this myself.
Shure: 这个签名啊
Shure: This signature.
Shure: 牛逼吧
Shure: Pretty awesome, right?
Katrina: 该火该火
Katrina: It should go viral.
Katrina: 这个什么时候能涨到多少ego币
Katrina: When will this reach how many ego coins?
Katrina: 买一下
Katrina: Buy it.
Katrina: 拍卖
Katrina: Auction it.
Katrina: 修树那个的亲笔签名拍卖
Katrina: Shure's autograph for auction.
Jake:修欢
Jake: Shure
Shure: 修硕啊哈哈
Shure: It's Shure, haha.
Jake:我看看我看看
Jake: Let me see, let me see.
Jake:这这什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake:白鸟词典
Jake: Hundred Birds Dictionary.
Shure: 鸟词典
Shure: Bird Dictionary.
Jake:鸟在哪啊
Jake: Where's the bird?
Shure: 鸟
Shure: Bird.
Lucia: 我刚才一直在拿他这个
Lucia: I was just holding his thing.
Shure: 然后这是繁体的那个言字旁
Shure: And then this is the traditional "yan" radical.
Shure: 然后配合上这边是词
Shure: And on this side is "word".
Jake:噢噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure: 然后把这所有都遮住
Shure: And then cover all of this.
Shure: 这是个点
Shure: This is a dot.
Jake:可以是吧
Jake: Can we do this?
Shure: 是吧这个我绞尽脑汁想了半天
Shure: Yes, I've been racking my brains for this.
Jake:这花多少钱
Jake: How much did this cost?
Shure: 这是我自己写的
Shure: I wrote it myself.
Jake:哦不值钱是吧
Jake: Oh, so it's not worth much, right?
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 更值钱了吧不应该
Shure: It should be worth more, shouldn't it?
Jake:好好更值钱
Jake: Alright, it's worth more.
Jake:值钱值钱
Jake: It's valuable, valuable.
Shure: （歌词）我倒下后
Shure: (Lyrics) After I fall
其他人：这个被他搞的
Others: This is his doing.
其他人：被那个用多了
Others: He's used it too much.
其他人：搞不了
Others: Can't be fixed.
Shure: 油没了是吗
Shure: Is the oil gone?
其他人： 有这么快就没了吗
Others: Did it run out that quickly?
其他人：有可能
Others: It's possible.
Jake:有可能
Jake: It's possible.
Katrina: 谁买瓜子
Katrina: Who bought the sunflower seeds?
Jake:你知道他叫什么吗
Jake: Do you know what his name is?
Jake:英文名
Jake: His English name.
Shure: 他吗
Shure: His?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 古希腊
Katrina: Ancient Greece.
Katrina: 不知道他不
Katrina: Don't know, does he?
Jake:他叫他叫古希腊
Jake: His name is Ancient Greece.
Shure: 真的吗他叫古希腊
Shure: Really, his name is Ancient Greece?
Jake:他叫古希腊对
Jake: Yes, his name is Ancient Greece.
Katrina: 你听过这首歌没
Katrina: Have you heard this song?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Jake:叫古希腊
Jake: Called Ancient Greece.
Katrina: 因为我本来有个同学也一直叫那个名字
Katrina: Because I had a classmate who was always called that name too.
其他人：你觉得是没油了还是打火石
Others: Do you think it's out of oil or the flint?
其他人：还是棉芯应该是棉芯
Others: Or the wick, it should be the wick.
Shure:  是没油了没油了
Shure: It's out of oil, out of oil.
Jake:哎你线拿下来了
Jake: Hey, you took the wire down.
Shure: 没了你加点酒精吧
Shure: It's gone, add some alcohol.
Shure: 要不呵呵呵
Shure: Or else, haha.
其他人：加酒精要把我杀了
Others: Adding alcohol will kill me.
Shure: 不会
Shure: It won't.
Shure: 他只会整个都烧起来
Shure: He'll just set the whole thing on fire.
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How is it?
Jake:挺好挺暖和挺暖和的
Jake: Pretty good, pretty warm, really warm.
Tasha: 拔错吧
Tasha: Wrong plug, right?
Jake:我看看去
Jake: Let me check it out.
Jake:我是个
Jake: I am a...
Shure: 卧槽这好屌啊
Shure: Whoa, this is so cool.
Shure: 这
Shure: This...
Jake:我看看我是个什么东西
Jake: Let me see what I am.
Shure: 我你现在特潮
Shure: Man, you look so trendy now.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Tasha: 特潮
Tasha: So trendy.
Shure: 你薅白头发吧
Shure: Pull out the white hair.
其他人：把我白头发薅了
Others: Pull out my white hair.
其他人：我他妈头全没了哈哈哈
Others: Damn, my whole head is bald now, hahaha.
Katrina: 我就要这个请认准了
Katrina: I just want this, make sure you get it right.
Shure: 好古奇呢
Shure: What about Gucci?
Jake:确实挺好看
Jake: It really looks good.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake:是吧挺潮的确实
Jake: Right, it's quite trendy, indeed.
Shure: 太潮了真的
Shure: Super trendy, really.
Shure: 你今天就这样
Shure: You're just like this today.
Jake:我就我今天就这样
Jake: Yeah, I'm just like this today.
Jake:这是一个大勋章是不是
Jake: This is a big medal, isn't it?
Shure: 这是
Shure: This is...
Shure: 你可以叫Supernova
Shure: You can call it Supernova.
Shure: 超新星
Shure: Supernova.
其他人： Katrina
Others: Katrina.
Shure: Katrina
Shure: Katrina.
Jake:哪呢这个
Jake: Where is it?
Jake:这就是短腿的
Jake: This is the short-legged one.
Jake:哦这长腿
Jake: Oh, this is the long-legged one.
Shure: 倒
Shure: Collapse.
Shure: 北邮也火了
Shure: Beiyou is famous now.
Shure: 什么着火了是吗
Shure: Something caught fire, right?
Jake:这个是长腿
Jake: This is the long-legged one.
Shure: 北邮阳台抽烟把把衣服点着了
Shure: Someone smoking on the balcony at Beiyou set their clothes on fire.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Jake:这什么地方啊沙河
Jake: Where is this place, Shahe?
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehe
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：阳台抽烟把什么
Others: Smoke on the balcony, right?
Jake:面包大学是什么
Jake: What is Bread University?
Shure: 不知道什么叫面包大学
Shure: Don't you know what Bread University is?
Shure: 老学长们都已经不懂这个梗了是吧
Shure: Even the seniors don't get this joke, huh?
Jake:确实不懂
Jake: Yeah, I don't get it.
Jake:你知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
Shure: 我也不知道
Shure: I don't know either.
Jake:那你们也老觉得
Jake: So you guys also...
Shure: 我也老学长了
Shure: I'm also a senior.
Jake:不懂沙河的这些梗
Jake: Don't get these Shahe jokes.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha: 嗯剪刀呢
Tasha: Hmm, where are the scissors?
Katrina: 那个问答在谁那谁主持
Katrina: Who's got the Q&A? Who's hosting?
Katrina: 你吧
Katrina: You, right?
Shure: 我
Shure: Me?
Shure: 我是一个普通话一甲的主持人
Shure: I'm a host with top-notch Mandarin.
Shure: 哗啦啦雨在下不
Shure: Is it raining heavily?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Shure: 留好他
Shure: Keep it for him.
Shure: 有一天我真的
Shure: One day I'll really...
Shure: 这就是什么敢丢的魅力你懂吗
Shure: This is the charm of being bold, you know?
Jake:古希腊怎么拼
Jake: How do you spell Ancient Greece?
Shure: 自己也不会拼
Shure: I can't spell it either.
Katrina: 确实刚起的
Katrina: Yeah, just came up with it.
Jake:咔哇咔cartrina
Jake: Kawaka cartrina
Jake:okay cartrina
Jake: Okay cartrina
Shure: 来一杆子先
Shure: Let's do a round first.
Shure: 来得及不
Shure: Do we have time?
Tasha: 知道这是什么吗
Tasha: Do you know what this is?
Jake:这纸眼睛
Jake: This is a paper eye.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Tasha: 你知道这眼睛怎么用吗
Tasha: Do you know how to use this eye?
Jake:贴眼睛上
Jake: Stick it on your eye.
Tasha: 贴在哪都会很有灵魂
Tasha: Stick it anywhere, it'll look soulful.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 啊真的可以
Katrina: Ah, it really works.
Jake:贴眼睛上
Jake: Stick it on your eyes.
Tasha: 你把你手机拿出来
Tasha: Take out your phone.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 我们来
Shure: Let's do it.
Jake:你这线是谁的线
Jake: Whose cable is this?
Shure: 我的呀
Shure: It's mine.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Jake:那这线是谁的线
Jake: Then whose cable is this?
Tasha: 我的
Tasha: It's mine.
Jake:我的那你的线是谁的线
Jake: Mine? Then whose cable is yours?
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Tasha: 你的
Tasha: Yours.
Jake:那我这根线是谁的线
Jake: Then whose cable is this one?
Shure: 打扫卫生吧
Shure: Let's clean up.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh, come on.
Katrina: 这个垃圾盒要不要我们扔到外面去
Katrina: Should we throw this trash box outside?
Shure: 扔一扔扔一扔
Shure: Yeah, throw it out.
Shure: 我自己
Shure: I'll do it myself.
Shure: 咱们是应该买冰块的
Shure: We should buy some ice.
Katrina: 冰块不是有吗
Katrina: Don't we already have ice?
Shure: 但是不够应该
Shure: But it's not enough.
Katrina: 那再买
Katrina: Then buy more.
Jake:我的线是你的线
Jake: My cable is your cable.
Shure: 我靠这还有安格斯厚牛堡都没吃呢
Shure: Oh my, there's still an Angus beef burger that hasn't been eaten.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 太败家了吧
Shure: Such a waste.
Shure: 这一帮帮的
Shure: Look at this group.
Jake:还有两个
Jake: There's still two more.
Jake:两个
Jake: Two of them.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Shure: 两个我操
Shure: Two, damn it.
Shure: 太太过分了
Shure: This is too much.
Shure: 这么好的东西不吃
Shure: Such good stuff not being eaten.
Shure: 我天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake:咋办炒的吧
Jake: What should we do, fry it?
Jake:要不什么炒
Jake: Or should we fry something?
Shure: 什么炒了
Shure: Fry what?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 拿微波炉叮一下不就得了
Shure: Just microwave it.
Shure: 还炒了
Shure: It's still stir-fried.
Katrina: 可以直接这样冲吗
Katrina: Can we just brew it like this?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Yes.
Jake:呃可以可以
Jake: Uh, yes, we can.
Jake:确实确实可以确实可以
Jake: Indeed, we definitely can.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 我也喜欢
Tasha: I like it too.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 怎么怎么打扫呢
Shure: How do we clean this up?
Tasha: 拍一个那种那个加速
Tasha: Take a time-lapse video of the cleaning.
Shure: 哦可以哎
Shure: Oh, that's doable.
Shure: 杨老板可以在这立个固定机位
Shure: Jake, you can set up a fixed camera here.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Shure: 拍个延时视频
Shure: Record a time-lapse video.
Shure: 我们在这酷酷
Shure: We'll look cool doing it.
Shure: 收拾那什么哈哈哈
Shure: Cleaning up and all, hahaha.
Jake:哦哦哦这都有啊
Jake: Oh, oh, we have that too.
Jake:这一圈都可以拍
Jake: We can record this whole area.
Shure: 啊也也是
Shure: Ah, true.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 对啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, hahaha.
Tasha: 他连你下面的都想要
Tasha: He even wants what's underneath you.
Shure: 踹他一脚
Shure: Kick him.
Jake:这下面的现在应该还能买的到
Jake: You can probably still buy the stuff underneath.
Jake:对当时我觉得能买到也挺牛逼的
Jake: Yeah, I thought it was pretty awesome to get it back then.
Tasha: 要不要给你眼镜上贴两个超小的
Tasha: Do you want to stick two tiny ones on your glasses?
Jake:怎么贴
Jake: How do you stick them?
Shure: 我刚刚又给他发消息
Shure: I just messaged him again.
Shure: 他说你说的对
Shure: He said you're right.
Shure: 但今天我是你妈
Shure: But today, I'm your mom.
Katrina: 玩cosplay
Katrina: Playing cosplay.
Shure: 好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 就喜欢玩这种play吧
Shure: Just like playing this kind of play.
Shure: 越玩越变态了耶
Shure: Getting weirder and weirder.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Katrina: 你把饮料放楼上去
Katrina: Put the drink upstairs.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Shure: 咱先把表面的垃圾收拾收拾行不行
Shure: Let's clean up the surface trash first, okay?
Shure: 你又把这个喝了
Shure: You drank this again.
Shure: 然后晚上调了就没了是吧
Shure: And then you adjusted it at night, right?
Katrina: 我不喝
Katrina: I won't drink it.
Shure: 这都弄了
Shure: It's all done.
Shure: 哎呦我干嘛
Shure: Oh no, what am I doing?
Shure: 换个新衣服来收拾垃圾
Shure: Changing into new clothes to clean up the trash.
Katrina: 谁呀
Katrina: Who?
Shure: 我
Shure: Me.
Katrina: 这是什么啊
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 可可粉
Katrina: Cocoa powder.
Shure: 可可粉
Shure: Cocoa powder.
Katrina: 你让我妈看到这
Katrina: If my mom sees this...
Katrina: 我妈会崩溃
Katrina: My mom would freak out.
Shure: 丢
Shure: Throw it away.
Shure: 全丢
Shure: Throw it all away.
Shure: 抹茶实验室
Shure: Matcha lab.